while you were fighting ranala did you
ever wonder what words her children were
singing it's hard to make out with all
of the chaos going on around you but if
we extract just those voice lines from
this fight then we can hear or read this
so mother's amber is ranala's amber egg
within this egg is the great ruin of the
unborn a shard of the elden ring given
to ranala by radagon who is her former
husband and with this rune she rebirths
juvenile scholars over and over again
according to the juvenile scholar set
rebirth is as sleep to them and with
each awakening memory fades into
oblivion hence the lullaby sleep died
find life
now umbra is basically another word for
shadow specifically though an umbra
often refers to the region of darkest
shadow during a lunar eclipse so all of
a sudden this line becomes hugely poetic
ranala is the queen of the full moon and
her children are being reborn in her
umbra reborn in the shadow of her moon
one of the tiniest little secrets is
hidden in ranala's bracelets from her
queen set and when you equip these
bracelets you don't just equip the
bracelet you equip a tiny ring on your
little finger as well now i'm probably
reading too much into it but it's been
documented before that wearing a single
ring on your little finger can advertise
the possession of a costlier piece of
jewelry that's put away in store
and that's certainly the case with
ranala whose boss room has a locked
chest that contains rani's darkmoon ring
this is a ring of betrothal and it's
supposed to be given by rani to her
consort this ring was locked away by
princess rani herself the writing that's
engraved upon the ring reads whoever
thou mayest be take not the ring from
this place the solitude beyond the night
his better mine alone
but with this ring you can become
ronnie's consort and unlock a new ending
the ring goes on to say that rani is an
emperian and any consort of hers would
by right own the title of lord
so obviously betrothal was a really
important concept to the royal family
but rings aren't the only symbol of
betrothal in this family according to
the darkmoon greatsword it is
long-standing tradition for a queen of
caria to bestow a moon greatsword upon
her spouse and as such you receive the
darkmoon greatsword when ronnie takes
you as her consort at the end of her
questline that's why you receive this
sword as a reward now ranala was once
betrothed to radigan where then is his
moon greatsword
well it's actually in the game but it's
quite well hidden and you might not have
thought this was it when you looked at
it it's in the consecrated snow fields
wielded by a misbegotten crusader
it's the golden order greatsword it
doesn't look like a moon greatsword does
it well that's because it used to be one
greatsword made of light modeled after
the elden ring itself
forged by king consort radigan to
proudly symbolize the tenets of the
golden order telltale signs betray that
this was once the great sword bequeathed
to him by his first wife ranala now
rinala was once betrothed to radigan so
it wasn't just forged it was reforged
radigan fought for the golden order but
then he married ranala and was given a
moon greatsword then when he left ranala
to return to the golden order he
reforged his moonlight greatsword into
the golden order greatsword instead
as for why it's wielded by a misbegotten
crusader your guess is kind of as good
as mine i guess a few interesting things
to note here is that the misbegotten's
hair is red like ratagons and also just
that misbegotten in general always seem
to be in possession of these legendary
armaments there's also the grafted blade
greatsword in castlemorn for example as
well at the back of ranala's room there
is a statue of radigan despite him
leaving her so long ago
this is the same statue design that was
commissioned for the erd tree capital
the same statue that reveals that
ratigan is in fact america if you're not
familiar with the concept of ratigan
being america you should go and watch my
previous lore video the whole point of
that video is to lay the groundwork and
the foundations for all of the law that
i'll be discussing in the videos to come
i've actually got a few corrections for
that video that i'm going to talk about
at the end of this video so stay tuned
for that but back to the statue what i
want to talk about isn't the statue
exactly rather it's the backing of the
statue this crisscross pattern
this mesh it's actually really important
to ratigan as a character it's basically
like his seal it's his symbol
technically it's also his elden rune and
it is something that you start to notice
everywhere once you start looking for it
for example radigan's scar seal is an
eye engraved with an elden rune and his
mesh pattern is sealed on it
next we see this same pattern on the
door that blocks access to the herd tree
of course radigan is inside the urban
tree at this point and his seal is a
part of the door that prevents you from
entering next we also find it on the
mask of confidence in gold thread that's
sewn over the mouthpiece in a crossed
fashion you might think oh that's not
enough to relate it to radigan but the
description says when radigan married
ranala he ordered the carrion magic
preceptors to don these masks to make it
clear that all of their matters were to
be kept strictly private and as you
probably know radigan was indeed keeping
a lot of secrets i want to thank quailag
whose work on the law i respect a ton
for pointing out the masks to me and
finally maybe most importantly this
pattern is found on the main menu and on
the elden ring itself so why does the
elden ring have radigan's seal upon it
well this is probably a new element that
was added when radigan became the vessel
for the elden ring perhaps
it's now housed within him after all so
it makes some sense then that his seal
would be represented upon the symbol of
the elden ring in some way as well
but what does this mesh represent well
for one it's very orderly it matches the
complete character of radigan in terms
of a symbol
and i do think a bit of the character is
represented in the design because the
scar seal item goes on to clarify that
these seals represent the lifelong duty
of those chosen by the gods so maybe the
seal represents the type of duty that
the character takes on so we know that
radigan takes on a sort of repairing
role at some way so the mesh kind of
fits with that i feel like the stronger
version of the scar seal is the sore
seal and it goes on to read solemn duty
weighs upon one beholden not unlike
annoying curse from which there is no
deliverance and the red seals on these
eyes become so embedded in the eye that
the shape of the seal becomes barely
recognizable at this point it's a heavy
duty indeed
of course america has seal talismans as
well and as with radigan the talismans
reveal the shape of her seal as well and
hers is a crucifix you would have seen
this crucifix all throughout the lands
between it's present as the symbol of
the summoning pool but beyond that
you'll find a ton of crucifixes in
limgrave especially where there are
countless undying screaming bodies
pinned up i'll admit i have no idea why
these bodies only scream at night i have
no idea why they're being punished or
why they're smoldering so let me know if
you have any ideas on that america
herself is crucified like this within
the earth tree
you could interpret this as her being in
shackles for shattering the olden ring
after all the elden beast also likes to
punish us with a crucifix of its own but
beyond these shackles it's undeniable
that the pose did become a symbol of her
entire reign for example go and look at
the statues of america throughout the
game
all of them feature her with her hands
flung out to the side almost as if she's
mimicking the shape of the rune of death
you could also argue that's the same
pose that she has on her little
resurrection statues as well this woman
this god removed death from the land and
i think that this posture is the symbol
of that blessing the symbol of the rune
of death and the symbol of her seal now
the vertical line coming down through
the center of the elden ring is present
in almost all of the great runes symbols
and it really helps you when you're
trying to align them all back together
in photoshop to form the shape of the
elden ring it's almost like a guide and
this is the end result
but how many great runes do you really
need to complete the olden ring
well there would have been a point in
your playthrough where the two fingers
tell you that you only need to collect
two great runes to earn the right to
become elden lord and to restore the
golden order you might have thought this
was strange right how can the elden ring
be complete with just two great runes
well then you have to remember morgot
guards the ode tree and he's not an
optional boss and with his great rune
you have three so apparently three is
enough and the elden ring does start to
look pretty complete at that point
in fact even if you get every great rune
in the game and theoretically fully
restore the elden ring it's possible
that it's still not really complete from
a law point of view i mean for example
in farah missoula there's an even bigger
elden ring that has even more rings on
it if you count them all
nothing explicitly mentions this mega
elden ring in the game's descriptions or
anything so speculation is all we have
my best guess at this stage is that
maybe this is some sort of primordial
form of the olden ring since it has more
rings maybe this is something that
existed in an earlier age as for the
roots on the design i kind of interpret
this as the way that this helden ring
might have had its blessings filtered
down to the world in a more natural way
perhaps
elton ring will almost certainly receive
dlc the game's too popular not to and
it's bandai namco of course it will so i
wouldn't be surprised though if in that
dlc we were able to collect more great
rooms from a gameplay point of view it
makes sense there is a system for
equipping great runes in the game after
all but from a law point of view we do
also know that there is at least one
other great rune that we haven't found
yet
ronnie's
ronnie is said to have cast aside her
great rune
so here at the hold we seek the
whereabouts of the remaining three shard
bearers there was a really interesting
post a little while ago on the reddit by
user flint von evereck who proposed that
rani's great rune could have been hidden
on the moon itself which
i mean it just makes so much sense you
can see it up there and it makes so much
sense considering who she is it's an
amazing theory and an amazing find i
remember noticing that shape on the moon
so long ago in promotional material for
the game and it's crazy to think that
this symbol might have ended up having a
meaning like this another thing that we
speculated about ages ago before the
game was officially released was this
line of dialogue from margaret
cower in fear of the night
the hands of the fell omen shall brook
thee no quarter
now that the game is released i think we
have an explanation for why he says this
the hands of the fel omen might just be
the knight cavalry according to their
armor the knights cavalry who now wander
the dim roads at night were once led by
the fel omen
that said the set does make it clear
that they used to be led by the fel omen
and that they're not anymore i guess so
take that theory with a grain of salt i
guess and in fact you should always be
taking what i say with a grain of salt
especially in these early days as we're
still all figuring out the law for
example since posting my recent law
explained video i've developed my own
theories further and i've read and
listened to some much needed criticisms
and unfortunately i do think that there
are some parts of that video that are
just wrong so to try and prevent some of
those theories spreading i've actually
spliced out specific sections of that
video in the youtube editor
i still think the video is well worth
watching i still think it's got good
fundamentals in it
but in case you have watched that video
already i'm going to take some time now
to just update you all on how my ideas
have changed
first off there's a small part of that
video where i call the erd tree a
parasite so
parasite was kind of the wrong word to
use there i think calling it parasitic
kind of characterizes the odd tree as
sinister you know just for feeding off
an energy source which is wrong
obviously it's a tree that's what trees
do
in the words of quelaag another law
creator that i mentioned earlier the erd
tree is more symbiotic if anything i
think symbiotic is a good word because
we know that the earth tree was
symbiotic with one thing at least and
that was the great tree root resin tells
us that the odd tree's roots were once
entwined with that of the earth tree so
it clearly was merged with it on some
level now in my video i also put forward
that the great tree was where the
crucible of life was located and that
this great tree and that the power
source that it had was likely what third
tree drew upon for its power
now i don't necessarily think i'm wrong
on this but i definitely should have
shown my reasoning a little bit better
so now i'd like to point out if only
briefly that my main piece of evidence
for the great tree being the location of
the crucible of life is crucible knight
solutions tree helm this is a crucible
helmet that features great tree
ornamentation and to me if these knights
were fashioning their gear after the
great tree specifically then that's a
fairly strong connection between the
crucible and the great tree to me
however it bears mentioning that no item
descriptions explicitly link the
crucible with the great tree so it's all
indirect evidence so i just want you to
bear that in mind and come to your own
conclusions on that topic next i
probably should have elaborated when i
said that america killed the fel god she
didn't rather as per the one-eyed shield
it's believed that she killed the fel
god of course other descriptions like
flame of the fel god make it clear that
the fel god still lurks within the fire
giants and we'll go into more detail on
that later at any rate she certainly
suppressed the power of the fel god you
could say she defeated it but it's
clearly still a force in the world and
lastly i've removed the statement that
millennia and mykola were born after the
shattering this is probably the biggest
thing i want to correct and i'll correct
it properly in my demi-gods video
basically in my video i said that they
were born after the shattering because i
was assuming that they were born from a
single conjoined god after the
shattering but of course you can also
choose to believe that they were born of
ratigan and america before those two
gods were conjoined post-shattering so i
think it's more likely that the twins
were born before the shattering this
gives them time to grow up and interact
with other characters and gain their
fame so that makes more sense
i also no longer really believe that the
divine towers were built after the
shattering and i have removed that point
from the video as well so
thank you to those who critiqued me
politely i'm actually always happy to
admit that i'm wrong i'm going to make
more of an effort to have my scripts
peer-reviewed in the future to avoid
that from happening
but i'm not all-knowing not yet anyway
i've still got a lot more that i can
learn and this kind of segues into my
sponsor for this video which is audible
if you're looking to integrate
audiobooks into your life whether it's
to learn or to escape then you can
listen to any one audiobook from audible
completely free during your free trial
simply head over to audible.com
varietyvideo or text varity video to 500
500 and consider signing up if you want
to try an audio book that i love i'd
highly recommend feverdream by george
r.r martin himself it's the story of
abner marsh a struggling riverboat
captain who suspects that something is
amiss when he is approached by a wealthy
aristocrat named joshua york york looked
up
and their eyes met
till the rest of his days were done
abdermash remembered that moment that
first look into the eyes of joshua york
whatever thoughts he had had whatever
plans he had made were sucked up in the
maelstrom of york's eyes
boy and old man and dandy and foreigner
all those were gone in an instant and
there was only york the man himself the
power of him the dream so again head
over to audible.com
or text devotee video to 500 500 to
start your free trial thanks to audible
for sponsoring this video and thank you
for watching
you